the head of high school suggested an
alternative which was that i should only
share
white conservative views on race so i
should i should only have
conservatives who um you know had white
skin
unbelievable since that would not
confuse or inflame the students
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
teacher and educator at grace church
school in new york city who recently
wrote a piece on barry weiss's sub stack
titled i refuse to stand by while my
students are indoctrinated
and then you can guess what happened
next cancel culture
came to his door paul rossi welcome to
the reuben report
thank you dave it's a pleasure to be
here all right so
i've wanted to chat with you since i
read the piece
and we are going to link to the piece
below and i hope everyone will read it
but for people watching right now that
have no idea about any of this
can you sort of sum up the piece first
and then we'll kind of get into
everything that's happened since then
sure um basically uh for the last
i'd say four to five years there's been
an
increasing change in the culture of the
school
as it started to implement what it calls
and
it's anti-racist programming
in the grades that i you know in the
high school that i
teach so grades 9 through 12 there
and i've noticed um like a series of
very concerning things were happening
there
and uh basically a stifling of
expression
you know to the point where
kids were afraid to be silent they were
expected to say things
say the right things uh if they if they
didn't say the right things they were
flagged
as problematic in emails um and a lot of
this was designed to sort of create a
certain culture
um a culture that's based on
critical race theory essentially so um
you know i started to hear complaints
from some of my own some
students in the school some of my own
students some who weren't my students
um that this you know this was becoming
extremely
uncomfortable and difficult and really
poisoning the atmosphere
in the school and i watched i witnessed
some things myself
in you know meetings that were
segregated by race
so we would frequently have white's only
meetings and you know
bipac meetings black indigenous people
of color meetings
and so uh as there was also a
proliferation of
of you know uh opt-in affinity groups
you know so uh basically
this this notion that you know
individual
opinions and ideas had to conform to
your sort of racial group and gender
group
and you know when things differed from
that uh
it was seen as you know anomalous or you
know not representative of what you
should think
and i had some you know some experiences
in classes that i teach i'm a math
teacher primarily but there
there's i also teach a persuasion class
where
some of the students in my in that class
complained of of having sort of a bubble
mentality and they
they weren't getting any of the other
types of opinions so i suggested to my
head of high school that you know maybe
we could talk about
uh we could bring in some of the ideas
of professor glenn lowery at brown
nick brown economist i'm sure you're
familiar with his ideas
because the students well a lot of our
discussion focused around the
protests and riots over the summer so
they wanted to maybe hear an alternative
opinion but i was told by my head of
high school
that it would be extremely problematic
and disruptive
if um to students
of color and and other students if i
shared a conservative views of a black
man
right to be clear he happens to be a
black conservative he's
yes he happens to be a black that was
not even in my initial
proposal it was simply that he has
certain views on race
in the racial issues that you know may
differ slightly from what grace
church school is pushing sort of a
center right but still you know very
mainstream um you know if you look at
the opinions throughout the country
and the head of high school suggested an
alternative which was that i should only
share
white conservative views on race so i
should i should only have
conservatives who um you know had white
skin
since that would not confuse or inflame
the students
so this you know i didn't even respond
to that email i wound up not even
teaching that unit at all
and i just i was so disgusted by
by that response which i just see as
self-evidently racist
the notion that ideas should be filtered
the dissemination of ideas should be
filtered based on the color of the skin
of the person who's speaking them
and i it's just completely
anti-intellectual and regressive in my
opinion
subsequent to that there was a self-care
meeting during the pandemic which was
ostensibly designed to
help students cope with the struggles
and problems with being at home stuck
you know maybe they're not able to come
to school more than twice a week
and you know in this in this meeting up
came the white supremacy slide
um saying that some of the
characteristics of white supremacy
culture included things like objectivity
and individualism and uh most
interestingly enough
a right to comfort so in the meeting
which is supposed to be
sorry the segregated whites only meeting
that was supposed to be teaching
students how to feel
um you know more comfortable with this
with the
events that were surrounding them they
were told that if they were white they
should you know question their right to
comfort which i found the
the height of irony uh so uh then
then the facilitator was actually very
nice we got along
quite well i thought um raised the you
know
said asked the group of 200 students and
maybe 30 of my colleagues
you know whether they might be feeling a
white feeling
around these topics um and at that point
i
i decided to question uh what that
actually meant
a white feeling what makes a feeling
white and
it was you know i was i was a little
miffed and concerned
because i thought that this was
blatantly racist but i was gonna
try to present my questions in a in a
way that was
you know that wasn't antagonistic and
later she did speak to me and tell me
that she didn't feel that
my questions were you know offered in
bad faith or anything so
what i was what i wanted to do by asking
the question was to open up the
discourse a little bit so that students
may
see me as an example and maybe model for
them that it's okay to question ideas
it's okay to have different viewpoints
and that's exactly what happened so
students in the chat window of the zoo
meeting started to ask
you know a broader range of questions
even faculty joined in with some
questions of their own the facilitator
allowed it
there were a lot of questions against
capitalism so i put my own idea about
capitalism in there which was that
capitalism is extremely anti-racist
since it's done
more to lift people out of poverty lift
non-white people out of poverty than
than any other you know of its
competitors
um some of the questions that i put in
uh
also question the nature of racial
identification at all like why should i
identify as white why
why should i interject an identity based
on how other people see me why is that
necessary
and so that comment and some others made
their way out of the meeting sort of
violating the norm of confidentiality
to some folks that were not in the
whites only meeting and caused some
concern and agitation and then they had
to have meetings about the meetings and
then
it was sort of a week and a half of
upheaval
processing people felt harmed i was
brought into the
you know to speak to my head of school
and the assistant head of school
and i was you know asked you know how i
felt about what i had done
and i actually felt great so i said you
know i'm
i'm not contrite you know i i apparently
people are claiming that i've caused
harm but i
you know no one has come to me to
express this harm and and
you know they couldn't even explain the
causality of how my questions could have
caused the harm in the first place
and they kept raising the stakes when
they noticed that i wasn't contrite
and they said well you know you you've
caused grievous harm
you've disturbed the student's peace of
mind
and at the end when i wasn't contrite
they said you know you it's raised to
the level of harassment at that point i
just ended the meeting
i had a subsequent meeting with the head
of the whole school
and you know he reiterated his
disappointment he
he had some pretextual reasons for being
upset but clearly
what was causing the problems in the
school
were the nature of my questions
not necessarily some of the pretextual
things that surrounded it sure
yeah so okay so there's a lot there and
i know that for
for my my main audience that maybe
hasn't heard about this yet everything
you're saying is probably not that
shocking to them because i think
so many people have now seen this sort
of woke thing
infect so many schools and you know high
schools and colleges and now
virtually every institution and
everything else so all this is happening
and was there a moment where you like
what was it in you that was like i have
to say something now because i think a
lot of people the question of the day is
sort of
what what makes people stand up because
i think we're watching a lot of people
fold
and i'm glad to see that not only did
you write the piece and got in touch
with barry and i'm curious how that
happened as well
but then are willing to do press after
and really keep you know walking through
the fire on this thing
well once it's you know once it started
to cascade i began to feel
a real sense of exhilaration and duty
that i was doing the right thing
so that carried me through up into the
present day
um i wasn't sure when i started to ask
what a white feeling was or ask these
things in the chat
um you know how it would play out i
hadn't planned it it
started something my impulse to do those
things initially was simply to
to provide a you know those questions
were genuine but i
asked them because i felt that students
needed to see a teacher
an authority figure model for them
how free discourse is conducted and i
hadn't seen anyone do that
before and i felt that this was
something that i could do
and as it started to cause all of this
chaos around me i realized
well this is actually pretty important
and the more chaos was going on
the more i actually felt that it was
important to pursue it
yeah i mean it's so extraordinary
because obviously you know the story of
brett weinstein at evergreen and
so much of my audience knows that story
of course and
we've heard so many versions of this so
then what how did you get in touch with
barry and how did this whole
article get written and and the whole
piece there
the public part of this you know not
just fighting back right yeah
right well um my contract
uh they offer a contract year to year
and so
in my contract my current contract
expires the end of august so i had to
sign the contract for the next
year by april 15th and part of the
contingencies of that contract were
that i attended restorative practices
designed by the office of community
engagement to address the harm that had
caused
students of color and other students in
the school
but they would not specify what those
practices would be until after i signed
so i was in a bind there so i found
incredible
you know some legal representation
through fair the foundation against
intolerance and racism
i spoke with barry who's in a on the
board of advisors
and you know she suggested that i write
a piece about my experiences and i wrote
um
i wrote 5 000 words at first i had a lot
to say
and then we edited it down to something
that was more digestible
and then i did another draft and then
she had some tweaks and then you know so
so the editing was very helpful but
those were all my words
and i'm really you know i'm really
pleased with the effect it's had
right so okay so you put the piece out
and then you know then then the hate
starts coming you know you get you get
support from some quarters of course
but then the hate starts rolling in and
then what's the next thing that the
school did because this is where it
really starts
kind of going off the rails well it is
interesting i mean i got
overwhelming support through predictably
through
through you know barry's subscribers and
you know
through an email that i that i had
placed there but
i was curious how the school was
reacting my contract you know this the
article came out in the 13th
my contract i had to sign by the 15th i
hadn't gotten back to them yet
and then on the 14th i believe i
received a threat from someone within
the school community
it was not a physical threat but it was
a threat to my livelihood my well-being
and it was basically everything but
so you know i reported the threat to the
administration
um i reported it to the head of school
um
and then they tried to use that as a
pretext to keep me out of the school
to keep me from teaching in the school
saying that you know well you maybe you
feel unsafe
because of this and i said no actually i
don't feel unsafe i'm merely bringing
this to your attention to something on
your radar you should take care of
and then they said they tried to reframe
this threat as an opinion
and they said they would pull the
opinions of the other students and
faculty to see if they felt safe with me
in the building
and so when they came back to me and
said no actually
your students don't want to be in your
classes so we need to keep you
home and in fact we're going to take
away all your classes
unbelievable okay so you know they they
were indifferent to my claim that
actually if someone makes a threat
aren't they the ones that should be
staying home right and why
why is the teacher punished for what you
know another person did
yeah unfortunately my lack of shock is
just well not only because i know
i know your story but i mean i just we
know this story over and over again
sort of false allegations then
gaslighting and reversing accusations
and
and all of these things okay so we're
going to play this audio clip now can
you can you just set up what happened
between you and the head of the school
to give a little context and then we'll
play it and then come back
sure so the head of school george
davidson sent a letter to the
whole community saying that i had you
know in my article
i had misrepresented um you know the
conditions at the school that i had
substantial omissions
in there and they reiterated their
commitment to anti-racism
and and they you know they offered me
they they
they relayed to the school that they had
offered me this chance to
participate in a in a in a sub-committee
of a committee
um that would be heavily supervised so
you know as to sort of try to co-opt
whatever what i was saying
um however their claim that i had you
know
misrepresented things or left omissions
i responded to that with my own letter
you know saying that um
you know i i actually had in
conversations with george
you know he had clearly acknowledged to
me that he had grave doubts about
the school's own policy and that he
specifically had said
that there was a problem with demonizing
whites at the school
so i released that letter publicly in
response to his letter
and then he released a letter back
saying that this was
in his words you know i misquoted him i
attributed to him things he had never
said nor would ever say in the press
my actions were unprofessional so he was
impugning my character
and and my veracity so at that point i
felt i had no choice
but to release you know clips of the
conversation which i had recorded
because i was worried that it might come
up in an
employment dispute right i mean it's
it's actually quite incredible because
you did this like an
absolute pro in terms of the emails back
and forth and then doing this recording
and well let's let's let the recording
stand on its own so let's throw to that
let me ask you something george because
i think those are i think there's
something very different
about having a single experience where
you
make sense of it right and having a
teacher an authority figure
talk to you endlessly every year telling
you
that because you have whiteness you are
associated with
evils all these different evils these
are moral evils it's not the same as
taking like
a physical thing because it doesn't
affect your your
your moral value that's the problem
the the the fact is
that i'm agreeing with you that there
has been a demonization
that we need to get our hands around
in the way in which people are doing
this understanding okay so you agree
that
we're demonizing kids we're demonizing
um kid we're demonizing white people
for being born and are some of our
students white people
what are some of our students white
people yes
okay so we're demonizing white we're
demonizing white kids
why don't you just say it right we are
using language that makes them feel
less than um for nothing that they are
personally responsible for okay so that
clip is quite extraordinary because in
essence
he's basically saying yes you're telling
the truth
yes so it felt kind of good i guess
at that point that that that you
released it
yeah i mean i if you back me up against
the wall and you call me a liar
well he left me no choice uh i have a
reputation that i have to protect
especially since i'll probably be
looking for another job soon
um additionally i want to make clear
that the word demonization
was his word i never suggested it to him
that is you know that's why i i was
actually quite shocked
that he felt that way and i was also
shocked
that he hadn't taken any action on it
because what does it mean if the head of
school
knows that students are being demonized
for their race
and does nothing except share it
privately with and saying publicly
something completely
different so this was just you know it
was gratifying in a way which is why i
kind of said thank you thank you but it
was also really disturbing
because nothing had been done or seemed
would be
planned to be done he did make some
mention about you know
they were going to have a meeting at the
end of the year or something about it
but
that seemed totally inappropriate to the
to how serious the problem was right so
so to
to bring this all to now actually so
there was a little confusion
i think at first whether you had been
let go or exactly what had happened
so you are still employed by the school
but they're just not letting you teach
is that
is that correct that's right that's
right um
as of now i still have email access um
i don't receive all of the
communications i'm not on all the
distribution lists as it turns out but
um you know at this point i still am uh
i still am connected to the school in
that way
um i have been asked to be on this task
force
but i think i've said all i really need
to say for them to
to work out it out themselves uh frankly
i don't think there's
much i need to add to that do you think
there's any chance i mean they've sort
of just in essence doubled down even now
after having
him be exposed i mean do you sense that
there's any chance that they will
reverse any of this is there any
evidence i mean this is
one of the key points of the whole work
thing they don't seem to respond to
truth
and very well almost in every case they
double down
yeah they have put themselves uh in a
very a precarious position and this is
you know you know the expression between
a rock and a hard place
okay this is like that but instead of
being crushed they're being pulled into
opposite directions
so they're you know they've racialized
the atmosphere so much
and promised so much to different groups
that now
you know it's almost like i don't i
wonder
if they would at this point be able to
reverse course
given how deeply they've sunk their
commitment into this
divisive ideology i i don't
know if it's a problem that that can be
solved
um by changing course at this point
right in essence they can't because
they've gone so deep on teaching this
stuff that it would basically
point all of the the light shine all the
light on them
so so what do you want to happen at this
point i mean if you if you got an email
right now saying hey
you know you can come teach again is
that enough
uh no i want them to change this i want
them to actually
i don't want the school to be destroyed
i want i don't want to put
vulnerable students on the street i want
to simply allow for greater viewpoint
diversity
to have students all students feel free
to express their points of view and have
them discussed
openly in a spirit of you know of open
inquiry
um not to have their comments
judged simply by the color of their skin
which is what happens
uh i think and and with a lot of
students their
their points of view are labeled you
know as as
one of group of activist students
labeled white opinions
simply because they're uttered by a
white person
i think they need to completely revamp
the entire culture of the school to
allow for open inquiry
and that's what students have been
asking for
um to me personally so uh
i think that's really important i don't
want to i don't want the school to go
bankrupt i want the school to be a good
school
and that's how they could do it are you
shocked where you've gotten some support
and dismayed where you haven't gotten
some support
i'm overwhelmed by how much support i've
gotten frankly
i was expecting it to be like half
half hate and half support i would i
would be
i would be happy if that's what it was
but i think the
um the people that have reached out to
me have been overwhelmingly supportive
parents alumni at the school students
have said thank you so much for saying
this
we have been now that i'm in college i
look back on my high school and i feel
like
i remember feeling scared to say to to
express
myself in these classes uh i think
you know there are students at the
school now i think there's a substantial
percentage of students at the school now
that
are in support if not with my views
right
with my right to speak up and they would
they have supported my right to speak up
now they can't do it publicly they're
students but you know i i have
you know ways that you know people have
communicated to me
um so you know that inspires me that
that actually gives me a lot of hope
that may perhaps the worm is turning
and you know we'll see some changes
you know if not at grace but maybe in
some other schools we'll see
you know yeah well as i said to you
right before we started you know
everyone
that has been on my show that i've seen
step through this thing and walk through
that fire they're always stronger on the
other side whether it's brett weinstein
or lindsay shepherd or even james damore
anyone that's done it from an academic
angle or james did it obviously
at google whatever it is if you can get
through it then then you're pretty much
okay
if people want to find out more about
this or help you or reach out to you as
you said you might be looking for a job
soon
where can we direct them you can email
me at the email
teaching for truth at gmail.com
i i am the only one that has access to
that email no one else will see what you
send me and i will keep every
everything confidential if so and i also
respond to every email that i get so
please reach me there
i'm also volunteering currently for fair
the foundation against intolerance and
racism
and i've called uh i we're working to
set up chapters nationwide
uh with parents and and students and
you know other people to to basically
push back and create
a common culture based on you know
fairness understanding and humanity
we have to get back to a sane a sane
approach
to to education and uh
i think fair can help yeah and fair
basically is stepping
into the vacuum where the aclu which
unfortunately has kind of crumbled under
a lot of these ideas has just
has just left the left the range so to
speak well paul i
i really appreciate you doing this and i
wish you luck and if there's anything i
can do to help you along the
along the ride please let me know i
think you already have dave this has
been great thank you so much for having
me all right great thank you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about academia
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our academia playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell